welcome to the third of this series in
her Stimson lectures on Britain Europe
grexit the future year of future Britain
by our distinguished doctor who is
currently or husband for while now
professor - university of london after
his time at Brasenose College in Oxford
where many of you been to either place
no no him over oh he is an author of so
many books on British constitution of
history an abridged Constitution he was
introduced in the first super Simpson
lectures this time last week and against
in the second lecture so I think I'm
going to save time we needed to go
running around getting extra chairs that
he's in general so we're starting a bit
late this particular lecture is on
brexit means brexit so we're getting
getting closer and closer to what you
all can to get the news about many what
on earth is going to happen over there
the fourth lecture is going to be in the
auditorium because we expect we will get
a further search of controls in the
lectures it would be chiefly on whether
Europe and where's Europe going there
will be time I hope a Q&A session after
this as her husband in the previous two
so please just join me in welcoming back
to the lecture podium Burnham bog to
normal inverter please take over
well thank you very much and I suppose I
ought to begin by apologizing for
bringing British weather with me across
the Atlantic but a colleague of mine at
King's College London professor of
European law tak East redeemeth said
that the referendum in 2016 which voted
to brexit by 52 to 48 percent but this
was the most significant constitutional
event in Britain since the restoration
of the monarchy in 1660 because it
showed or perhaps confirmed that on the
issue of Europe the sovereignty of the
people Trump's the sovereignty of
Parliament now the referendum Act passed
in 2015 which provided for the
referendum provided it should be an
advisory referendum and it was not
legally binding on Parliament but
nevertheless the government had said in
advance that it would be bound by the
result and the outcome even though the
majority was narrow was regarded by
almost all MPs as binding on them as
well and what it meant was that the
House of Commons for the first time in
its history was enacting legislation in
which it did not believe because around
75% of the members of parliament are
remain as a majority even if the
Conservative MPs had supported remain a
majority of the cabinet and a very large
majority of the House of Lords
so the sovereignty of parliament was now
being constrained not legally but
practically not by Brussels but by the
people and this is very fundamental
because parliament has traditionally
been at the center of British
constitutionalism in the sense that it
is not for the legislature of any other
country except possibly New Zealand it
certainly has a more central place in
Britain than the Continental
legislatures in the countries of the
European Union and the principle of
parliamentary sovereignty explains why
we don't have a
Constitution there's no point having one
if Polland is sovereign but even more
than that Parliament lies at the core of
British nationhood unlike for example
the Americans the British do not define
themselves in terms of values or in
terms of allegiance to a document much
less in terms of ethnicity but the
British define themselves as perhaps you
would expect in strictly empirical terms
to be British is to be represented in
Parliament now in the 18th century of
course the Americans could not be
represented in Parliament but it was
said that they were virtually
represented by British MPs and that
fiction of course was destroyed by the
Boston Tea Party and the British learnt
from that it was clear that Canadians
and Australians for example could not be
represented at Westminster that meant
they had to be represented in their own
local legislatures under the aegis of
what was called the Imperial Parliament
and that phrase the Imperial Parliament
was last used quite late by the Labour
Prime Minister Harold Wilson as late as
the 1970s when talking about legislative
devolution but it follows I think from
this the ideal of self-government for
all colonies was in logic implicit in
the constitutional structure of the
British Empire so to be British is to be
represented the Scottish National Party
who don't wish to be represented because
they wish to be represented in a
Scottish Parliament in Edinburgh they
come to Westminster precisely to say
that that they come to say they do not
want to be there the Irish nationalist
party shin Fane go even further and do
not recognize Westminster at all they
don't attend and they say to be Irish is
incompatible with being British whereas
the unionist party in northern
and say that being Irish is like being
shall we say Welsh or as most Scottish
unionists and say Scottish and is as it
were a subspecies of being British so if
to be British is to be represented in
Parliament the people give their
representatives a mandate to act on
their behalf
indeed it used to be held that the
people were actually present in
Parliament through their representatives
but suppose these representatives seek
to transfer their powers away either
downwards through legislative devolution
or more important for our purposes
upwards to the European Union a superior
legal order the representatives have no
mandate to transfer those powers away to
get it the only way to get it is by
means of a referendum which gives them a
specific mandate from the people to
transfer their powers and therefore
whenever we have enacted legislation
devolution since the war at least or
whenever we had the decision about
joining the European Union or leaving
that is can only be achieved through a
referendum so from this point of view
the referendum in Britain far from being
a populist instrument populist
instrument follows the logic of liberal
Constitution ISM but the question is why
did the 2016 referendum lead to a
rejection of membership and that is the
question which I shall try to answer now
a Britain benefited considerably in
terms of economics from joining the
European Union in the form access to a
larger market and then in terms of
inward investment and once the effects
of the Middle East war of the 1970s and
the oil crisis were over these were
until the credit crunch golden years for
the European Union and Britain benefited
from those golden years but there were
problems
almost from the beginning the first was
Britain's net contribution which seemed
out of kilter with its its standard of
living and there was a long battle under
margaret thatcher's premiership
until that was resolved in 1984 in the
Fontainebleau agreement but then came a
much more serious problem of whether
Britain should join the European
monetary system and that was a system
which linked together the currencies of
the Member States to prevent
fluctuations between them and assist
trade established in 1979 it was
intended as a prelude to creation of a
common currency of the euro and as
Americans know better than anyone an
internal market requires a common
currency but the issue of whether we
should join that monetary system divided
the conservative cabinet down the middle
in the night late 1980s Margaret
Thatcher was against joining but her
leading ministers Sir Geoffrey Howe who
was foreign secretary then Deputy Prime
Minister and her Chancellor John Major
whose seat her of prime minister said
that we should join and gradually they
wore Margaret Thatcher down and we
entered the Exchange Rate Mechanism of
the European monetary system in October
1990 just a few weeks before Margaret
Thatcher's downfall in November 1990
which was also precipitated by a
European issue ironically by her
insistence on a view which most people
in Britain would now think was correct
by her insistence that Britain should
never join the euro now during the 1980s
party allegiances towards Europe changed
hitherto labour had been the more
Euroskeptic party believing that an
integrated Europe would inhibit the
development of socialism in Britain and
that is still the view of some on the
Left of the Labor Party but sadly for
pro Europeans that small number includes
the current leader of the Labour Party
Jeremy Corbyn and his allies
have done their best to inhibit the
pro-european sentiment of the majority
of Labour MPs and a majority of party
members but labor in general began to
swing towards greater sympathy to the
European issue in the 1980s under the
modernizing leadership of Neil Kinnock
whose period of leader may be regarded
as a prelude to the so-called new labor
era of Tony Blair in the 1990s the
Labour Party came to believe that the
European community far from being
antagonistic to its aims might actually
assist them and this change of view was
greatly helped by the President of the
European Commission dr. law who in 1988
spoke to the trade union Congress and
told them that many of the policies
sought by the trade unions which were
rejected by Margaret Thatcher's broadly
neoliberal conservative government could
be achieved through the social policies
of the European Community and the law
was a former socialist minister under
the government of France ometer are in
France and he said the trade unions
could get advances from Europe which
they couldn't get from Margaret Thatcher
Europe he said it had a social dimension
as well as an economic and political one
there had to be a balance any instant as
an example of this its policy of
providing protection at work declaring
it is impossible to build Europe only on
deregulation the internal market should
be designed to benefit each and every
citizen of the community it is therefore
necessary to improve workers living and
working conditions and provide better
protection for their health and safety
at work now as you can imagine that
speech help to bring labour supporters
around the idea of the European
community was a good thing but it had
perhaps the more serious disadvantage of
alienating market Thatcher and many in
her conservative government and just a
few weeks later Margaret Thatcher
responded to the law in her bruised
lecture of 1988 a lecture which has
attracted iconic status among
Euroskeptics and in her lecture she said
the character of the European community
had changed from the world
since the Treaty of Rome in 1957 the
treaty she said had been intended as a
charter for economic liberty but that
philosophy was now being undermined by
the development of monetary union and
proposals for a common currency and also
by proposals of the kind that the law
was advocating for a so called social
Europe we have not she said successfully
rolled back the frontiers of the state
in Britain only to see them reimpose at
a European level with the European
super-state exercising a new dominance
from Brussels but the law speech led her
to believe that European integration
meant socialism and that was a mirror
image of the earlier view of a labor
left still held by Corbin that European
integration meant domination by the free
market that it was a neoliberal project
she said domination by government they
said domination by the market but I
think both were wrong now although the
Bruges speech was welcomed by
Euroskeptics Margaret Thatcher insisted
she was not European or anti European
Britain she said does not dream of some
cosy isolated existence on the fringes
of the community
Britain's destiny is in Europe a part of
the community indeed if you read a
speech today it's conceived can seem
positively pro-european so much as
opinion shifted she called for example
for stronger defence and foreign policy
cooperation between member states and
insist in just a year before the
collapse of the Berlin Wall that and I
quote we shall always look on Warsaw
Prague and Budapest as great European
cities city cities the speech prefigured
has support for the enlargement of the
European Union to include the ex
communist states and enlargement largely
completed in 2004 and he's very ironic
that the two major contributions to the
European Union made by Britain were both
made by Margaret Thatcher the single
internal market in in in Europe and
enlargement
but she wasn't as it were prepared to
take the credit for these constructive
achievements and nor was anyone else and
the pro-european parts of the Bruges
speech made little impact because its
significance of the speech was quite
different that it was the first frontal
attack in Europe on what might be called
the community method integration for
money method the Schumann method if you
like what Margaret Thatcher was
attacking was the idea of supranational
tea and a sharing of sovereignty Europe
she said instead should develop through
inter governmental cooperation between
independent sovereign states nation
states were intractable political
realities she said which it would be
folly to seek to override or suppress in
favor of a wider but as yet theoretical
European nation hood she therefore
offered an alternative intergovernmental
vision of Europe a goalless division of
a Europe des 8r and that was in many
respects prescient the eurozone crisis
of 2012 was resolved less by the
integrationist institutions the
Commission and Parliament which were
pushed in the background but the
European Council composed of Heads of
Government and Margaret Thatcher's view
of Europe came to be espouse to some
extent in another bruise lecture which
is much less often read but I think is
at least as important by the German
Chancellor Angela Merkel in 2010 in
which she too emphasized the
intergovernmental method as opposed to
the integrationist method but before the
Bruges speech Margaret Thatcher had made
this most important contribution to
Europe by the single European Act of
1986 an amendment to the Treaty of Rome
arguably the most important of all the
amendments and that was an
integrationist development but
championed by Margaret Thatcher because
she believed it was in Britain's
interests and it transformed the
European Union from what it had been
before a free trade area and a customs
union into an internal market that is
the removal of non-tariff barriers to
trade which in the modern world are I
believe more important than
tatev so it converted as it were
external markets in the various member
states into a single internal market
I suppose that was also an American
process in the nineteenth century now
Margaret Thatcher favored that because
she believed it was in Britain's
interest but the preamble to the single
European Act refers to another aim
namely the progressive realization of
European monetary union which the
Continental leaders took to be a
corollary of internal markets and to
that ambition now get fatter remains
adamantly opposed this however did not
prevent her from signing the act and she
made no objection at the time in her
memoirs she does not take the easy way
out of saying that she was deceived by
her officials instead what she says is
this I had one overriding positive goal
this was to create a single common
market the price weak which we should
have to pay to achieve a single market
with all its economic benefits was more
majority voting in the community there
was no escape from that because
otherwise particular countries would
succumb to domestic pressures and
prevent the opening up of their markets
it also required more power for the
European Commission but that power must
be used in order to create and maintain
a single market rather than to advance
other objectives so for her qualified
majority voting should be restricted to
matters connected with a single market
not for example matters such as health
and safety at work or taxation policy
but that was not the view of the other
Member States
Margaret Thatcher saw the internal
market as in a sense a kind of World
Trade Organization arrangement for
non-tariff barriers as a kind of
extension of a free trade agreement but
a single internal market requires as of
course Americans have discovered
political and juridical regulation it
requires for example effective
competition law if the market is to be
effectively policed it is therefore not
possible in my opinion to make margaret
thatcher's distinction between the
creation of a single market and further
integration the single market requires
integration but on the continent
integration was not deplored but
welcomed to help secure the aim of
Greater European unity the aim of ever
closer Union but this was the issue the
question of whether the internal market
required further integration that was
the issue which divided her from the
conservative Pro Europeans though the
real issue so it seems to me was what
shape and form integration should take
there are many nuances to the notion of
integration as again Americans have
discovered and are very aware and the
question was whether Britain would be
able to play a part in helping to decide
the shape and form of that integration
or whether she would not now most
important of all amongst the Continental
leaders that de lor the most activist
president the European commissioners had
he he insisted that the logic of the
market internal market entailed monetary
union and a common currency and the
first step in that exercise was to
create a European monetary system of
fixed exchange rates and the zone of
monetary stability in Europe and the law
believed this was absolutely necessary
if the common price system of the Common
Agricultural Policy was to be effective
to encourage trade between member states
and above all to give Europe more weight
in a world economy dominated by a
volatile American dollar so for this
reason he favored a European system of
fixed exchange rates and in fact
monetary union had long been an aim of
the community indeed since 1969 before
Britain had actually joined now some
leading conservatives supported this
first step towards currency union though
most were opposed to the single currency
itself because they believed that
membership of the monetary system
would help to control inflation in
Britain by locking Britain into the
monetary discipline of the continent
particularly Germany with its strong
anti inflationary stance Margaret
Thatcher's view was that fixed exchange
rates were a mistake because they led to
market distortion in her attempt the
exchange rate mechanisms an attempt to
control the market and so went against
economic rationality it sought to yoke
together two very different economies
the British and the German and what was
right for one might not be right for the
other and given Germany's powerful
economic position the danger was that
Britain's economic policy might be
determined not by what was in Britain's
interests but by what was in Germany's
or by an economic standard that Britain
could not match and one of Margaret
Thatcher's favorite aphorisms was if you
try to back the market the market will
buck you now Europe was to be the
occasion though perhaps not the sole
cause of Margaret Thatcher's downfall
because her growing euro skepticism was
arousing the ire of her Deputy Prime
Minister Sir Geoffrey Howe who'd been
foreign secretary from 1983 to 1989 then
was Deputy Prime Minister and he
resigned in November 1990 and he said it
was the issue of Europe that had caused
him to resign it bled for tragic
conflict of loyalties with which I have
myself wrestled Thor perhaps too long
and he called his memoirs conflicts of
loyalties
on the last page of which he says I
wanted to change the policies not the
leader but if that meant the leader had
to go so then it had to be now at that
time as I've said Britain had just
joined the Exchange Rate Mechanism
of a monetary system and that was very
widely welcomed by almost all elements
of British society by the Labour Party
the Liberal Democrats the main employer
and trade union organisations and
Federation of Rhodesia Industry Trade
Union Congress it was imposed by just
eleven Conservative MPs who voted
against joining and a few MPs from the
left wing of a Labour Party
but some years later one of Margaret
Thatcher's allies said when Margaret
Thatcher is dead and opened it will be
those three letters Exchange Rate
Mechanism erm that will be lying on her
heart now whether that was so or not
joining was one of the last significant
decision she made six weeks later she
was removed from office in her
resentment against joining she said at
an EU summit in Rome that the EU leaders
were living in cloud cuckoo-land and
Britain would never agree to the single
currency and would seek to veto it a
declaration she repeated in the House of
Commons and that broke the cabinet
consensus on policy which was that while
Britain should certainly not join in the
immediate future it should not be ruled
out because ruling it out would in the
view of the cabinet leave Britain
isolated in the European Union and
Geoffrey Howe in particular believed it
was important for Britain to as it were
stay in the game and not be seen
specifically to choose a different
destiny in his resignation speech which
was devastating how said the Prime
Minister's perceived attitude towards
Europe is running increasingly serious
risks for the future of our country and
this precipitated a leadership challenge
which proved fatal to Margaret Thatcher
out of office she became more
Euroskeptic and in her book statecraft
which is well worth reading that I
myself to not agree with it but it's
well worth reading he published in the
mid-1990s she wrote that in the 20th
century
Britain's problems had all been caused
by Europe but had been resolved by the
anglo-saxons amongst whom she counted
the Americans British membership of the
European Community she went on had been
and I quote a political error of
historic magnitude Britain should
therefore renegotiate so as to recover
her sovereignty and he that proved
impossible to achieve of it
most certainly would be she should leave
what had become the European Union and
many years later Nigel Farage the leader
of the United Kingdom Independence Party
said that were Margaret Thatcher still
alive there would be no need for you Kip
at all it's a paradox as I say that
Margaret Thatcher to whom the EU largely
owes Britain's to constructive
achievements to the enterprise a single
market in enlargement was to turn
against Europe and this Illustrated an
internal tension or perhaps
contradiction within Thatcherism now the
internal market brought economic success
to Britain and gave her some of the
benefits of globalization and often seen
it often seen as a per blind nationalist
Margaret Thatcher but her championing of
the single market was a move towards
internationalism but it was achieved as
we've seen at the expense of both
national and parliamentary sovereignty
so one component of Thatcherism the
development of a free market in Europe
was polarized against another which is
national sovereignty and the question
therefore was was Britain prepared to
pay a price in terms of that loss of
sovereignty to secure economic benefits
and also no doubt the very real geo
political and diplomatic benefits that
Britain gained from being a member of
the European Union now it fell to the
Conservative Party to balance these very
real benefits against each other and
different conservatives do driven
through different conclusions some said
yes the price is worth paying others
said it was not and this tension I think
was bound to implode in the Conservative
Party and cause divisions which are
still very much present Margaret
Thatcher's successor as Prime Minister
was a chancellor John Major he
immediately struck a new note declaring
my aim for Britain in the community can
be simply stated I want to be where we
belong at the very heart of Europe he
successfully negotiated the Maastricht
Treaty in 1992 which also extended the
European Union's right of initiative
into
many new airs of policy and showed that
the European Union was moving from a
concerned solely with economics to the
political area and there were provisions
in the Maastricht Treaty requiring every
member state to join the common currency
but John Major through very skillful
negotiation secured an opt-out for
Britain and this meant that Britain
would not unlike all the other member
states except Denmark which also had an
opt-out Britain would not be legally
required to join the Euro it's fair to
say at some of the other member states
which are legally required have no
intention whatever of doing so and one
senior polish officials said to me
the polls are five years away from
joining the Euro and always will be but
Britain's troubles were by no means over
with the opt-out from Maastricht because
membership of the European monetary
system was proven increasingly difficult
as a result in large part of German
reunification and this proved to be
inflationary since wages and social
benefits in the depressed East had to be
raised to the same level as in the West
and the German Chancellor Helmut Kohl
chose a rate of exchange or one-to-one
between the West German deutsche mark
and the East German Ostmark although
obviously Ostmark
was worth much less than a Dutch mark in
addition Kohl shows to finance
reunification not by raising tax Asian
but by borrowing and in consequence
Germany had to raise interest rates now
higher interest rates might have been
appropriate for Britain in 1990 when she
was still suffering from the effects of
a property fuelled boom but by 1992
Britain was in recession and the need
was to reduce interest rates not to
raise them so as Margaret Thatcher had
predicted the Exchange Rate Mechanism
was leading not to the convergence of
the British and German economies but to
their divergence and British policy was
being influenced not by what might be
right for Britain but by what was right
for Germany and of course many of argue
that would have
and if Britain had joined the eurozone
now by the summer of 1992 the markets
had come to the view the British
government lacked the resolve to
implement the necessary measures of
economic and financial discipline needed
to sustain her continued membership of
the Exchange Rate Mechanism market
predictions proved self-fulfilling and
as Margaret Thatcher had predicted the
attempt to batma market led to Britain
being backed by the market Britain
sought help from the German central bank
the Bundesbank and from German
politicians she did not get it the
Bundesbank refused to lower interest
rates below a token amount and indeed on
the day before Britain left Exchange
Rate Mechanism
the head of the Bundesbank very kindly
declared that weak currencies might have
to be devalued he did not want the
Bundys the Bundesbank to be tied to a
weak pound Germany had in any case been
less sympathetic to the project of
monetary union and France since she
believed she would lose control over
inflation and come to be at the mercy of
the financial indiscipline of other
European countries perhaps the Greek
crisis of 2011 shows she was right and
during the discussions with Britain the
head of the Bundesbank a Helmut
Schlessinger told the German Finance
Minister Tara vagal not to weaken he
said in 1948 remember we had nothing and
look what we have now we achieved it by
pursuing our own line of policies we
mustn't weaken now Germany was to be
much criticized by the British who
believed as I said in my last lecture
that since Britain was the center of the
world it was a duty of other countries
and in particular in post-war years the
American Congress to act as charitable
institutions towards her and Germany was
much criticized for acting according to
her own self-interest in his
autobiography John Major tells the story
of phoning the head of his policy unit
who was on a walking tour of Scotland
and this was before the days of the
internet or mobile phones and the head
of the policy unit had to go to a police
phone to answer the Prime Minister's
call and she said Prime Minister
I don't think we can rely on the Germans
the two police constables standing
nearby who had overheard replied without
knowing what she was talking about dead
right and in his memoirs John Major
comments that they certainly knew what
was what in world affairs now the
British criticism and did have something
to be said for it because after all the
Germans were a hegemonic power within
the system and surely had
responsibilities other than national
self-interest which went along with that
hegemonic power but a very obvious from
historical reasons the Germans do not
like exercising that hegemonic power and
do not wish to accept the
responsibilities that go with a hegemon
and Americans can understand that
because they too have conflicts about
being a hegemonic power but the Germans
always insisted they were committed
Europeans and favoured European
solutions to problems though by a happy
coincidence those European solutions
always seem to be those which suited
German national interests but anyway
they became the convenient scapegoat for
British problems now on what was called
Black Wednesday though the Euroskeptics
called it white Wednesday Britain was
forced out of the European monetary
system with a lot of around 3.3 billion
pounds in foreign currency reserves
conservative opinion poll ratings fell
from 43 to 29 percent and did not
recover even though leaving the European
monetary system did not have the
catastrophic consequences that many
predicted indeed it led to a period of
low inflation though whether this was a
result of membership remains a matter of
dispute amongst economists I think it
was President Truman who said he wanted
to meet a one-handed economist because
every economist said that on the one
hand is this and on the other hand that
and and that's true of the effects of a
monetary system but perhaps best summed
up by Sir Alan Budds who was chief
economic adviser to the Treasury from
1991 to 1997 and he later wrote the
period of membership of the exchange
rate may
was not a very worthy episode a slightly
cruel summary of it would be to say that
we went into the Exchange Rate Mechanism
in despair and left in disgrace
nevertheless we are still enjoying the
benefits of it but the benefits took
time to arrive the immediate economic
consequences were catastrophic
during the first nine months of 1992
there were nearly 36,000 bankruptcies
and nearly 25,000 company liquidations
over 68,000 properties were repossessed
and over 200,000 property owners found
themselves in mortgage payment arrears
GDP growth was negative
- 2.2 percent in 1991 and minus 0.6
percent in 1992 and the hardship was
felt most strongly amongst the core
conservative or Thatcherite constituency
small businesses and the self-employed
they were devastated by the economic
collapse and the repossessions and
mortgage arrears seemed to put an end to
the conservative dream of a
property-owning democracy the political
consequences were as you can imagine
very serious and one conservative
backbencher declared for the departure
from the Exchange Rate Mechanism was the
biggest humiliation for Britain since
Suez it was a political chess trophy for
the major government ruining the
reputation for good economic management
that conservative governments had on the
whole enjoyed since 1951 and it was
largely for this reason the party
remained in opposition for so long after
1997 in the aftermath of withdrawal
taxes had to be raised and this
prevented the Conservatives from tagging
labour in the 1997 election as they'd
done in 1992 as the party of high
taxation the Conservatives were now
tagged as the party of devaluation and
labour for the first time since the
1970s was coming to be seen by the
voters as more competent in Economic
Affairs than the Conservatives in the
2005 election campaign labour Prime
Minister Tony Blair said the
Conservatives used to run on the economy
now they run away from it they were
not to recover their reputation for
nearly twenty years until they'd lost
three general elections and perhaps most
important from our point of view the
exits from the Exchange Rate Mechanism D
legitimized to pro Europeans in the
Conservative Party they the euro skeptic
said that leaving it enabled Britain to
devalue and led to economic recovery and
they called it not black Wednesday but
white Wednesday since it restored to
Britain the freedom to make her own
economic policy and the ERM debarked
have made it absolutely certain that
Britain would not join the eurozone and
not one opinion poll has ever shown in
Britain a majority for joining and the
Euro skeptics pointed out if we were to
join the Euro we could not devalue as
the Greeks Italians and others have
discovered so be locked into something
that was not suitable with British
economy during the Greek eurozone crisis
of 2011 Foreign Secretary William Hague
was to compare the eurozone to a
building on fire with no exit the euro
skeptic said the commitment to Europe
was a policy of the pre Thatcher days of
failed conservatism an aberration a
departure from true conservatism which
depended not on integration but the
primacy of the nation so true conserved
his must be Euroskeptics Margaret
Thatcher shared that view in her maiden
speech in the Lord's she said the
Maastricht Treaty was retreated too far
there should be a referendum on it she
said and if there was she would vote
against it and departure from the
Exchange Rate Mechanism started a civil
war in the Conservative Party which
still rages at the 1992 party conference
the first after we left the Foreign
Secretary Douglas Hurd pleaded with
delegates to remember the disastrous
effects of two previous splits in the
party both on issues connected with free
trade and protection and issues which
raised profound issues of national
identity the split over the Corn Laws in
1846 and the split over tariffs reform
in nineteen three the first kept the
Conservatives out of a majority
government for 28 years
second for 17 years let us decide to
give that madness amiss he pleaded but
his plea fell on deaf ears and Europe
was to keep the Conservatives out for 13
years
a former Conservative Minister very
close to Margaret Thatcher a former
chairman of the Conservative Party
Norman Tebbit called the Exchange Rate
Mechanism the eternal recession
mechanism and he asked the delegates and
a very rabble-rousing speech three
questions do you want to be citizens of
a European Union to which of course they
all shouted out no do you want to see a
single currency they will shout Downton
No do you want to let other countries
decide Britain's immigration policy to
which they all shouted out no and these
years began the chain of events which
led to the brexit referendum of 2016 now
the European issue was relatively
quiescent during the period of the Pro
European labour governments of Blair and
Gordon Brown
but then until 2008 but in 2010 the
Labour government was replaced with a
conservative Liberal Democrat coalition
government led by David Cameron and that
was the first peacetime coalition
government we've had since 1931 and who
could only be formed because Europe at
that moment was quiescent because the
conservative the euro skeptic but
Liberal Democrats the most Pro European
Party in Britain and David Cameron when
he became leader of the Conservative
Party's first conference speech as
leader in 2006 he said he wanted to stop
the Conservatives in his own words
banging on about Europe to forget about
an issue which was dividing the party in
which he thought had little resonance
with the British public and he said the
concerti should concentrate on the
problems really worrying people like the
condition of the public services and
particularly the National Health Service
but Europe was to become a salient issue
again very rapidly after that coalition
government was formed the prime reason
being mass immigration from Central and
Eastern Europe following enlargement
in 2004 now the ex communist countries
had a far lower standard than almost all
of the existing Member States and its
people felt a magnetic attraction
towards the west and particular to
Britain with it developed welfare
provisions and National Health Service
in British governments seriously
underestimated the scale of the
immigration which was to occur between
1881 and 1914 around three hundred and
twenty five thousand Jews immigrated
into Britain from Eastern Europe between
the years 1933 and 1939 around a further
fifty thousand came from Nazi Germany by
the time of a 1971 immigration act which
stopped the permanent migration of
workers from the Commonwealth there were
around 600,000 British citizens born in
the Commonwealth living in Britain and
these includes a very small number would
come to Britain before 1939 but mostly
post-war in 1972 around 30,000 Ugandan
Asians expelled by President Amin were
emitted admitted to Britain but there
are now in Britain around 3.7 million
migrants from the European Union so it's
been of a quite different level of
magnitude from previous waves of
immigration and whereas from 1962
immigration from the Commonwealth could
be controlled immigration from the
European Union could not be so
controlled and this had not been
foreseen in the Treaty of Rome which had
been signed by six countries of roughly
similar living standards and before the
age of mass transit but the admission of
the ex communist countries in the
poorest of which Romania income per head
was just over one-fifth of that in
Britain all - the situation now most
economists believe that India emigration
was good for Britain and indeed Tony
Blair's Labour government had encouraged
it to overcome shortages of labour but
many in the poorest sections of the
community felt it to be discerned for
advantageous
and for them immigration seemed
primarily to have benefited the elite
who could hire efficient polish builders
and lithuanian up airs the benefits
seemed less obvious for the left behind
on low incomes even though the
economists said they were there because
they believe that an unlimited supply of
immigrant labor kept wages low and the
benefits in the form of an increase in
tax revenues were not visible while
difficulties in the public service like
long hospital waiting lists waiting
times at doctors surgeries overcrowded
classrooms were very visible and were
largely mistakenly attributed to the
incursion of immigrants in addition many
amongst the poorest sections of the
community found it difficult to cope
with the social effects of immigration
the transformation of their communities
by people whose first language is not
English
unlike the Commonwealth immigrants and
this had occurred so they said without
their consent without their having been
asked and they argued that it undermined
the sense of reciprocity which was the
basis of the welfare state because they
took the view that access to benefits
should depend upon contributions and not
be available on the same basis to recent
immigrants who had not had the chance to
contribute and they said the basis of
citizenship was a joint enterprise
between citizens so mass emigration
yielded a disconnect between the elites
and the people and it was symbolized in
an iconic and in my view very important
episode in the 2010 general election
campaign in which the Prime Minister
Gordon Brown defending his position was
campaigning in Rochdale where he met a
Labour voter who told him she was
worried about the scale of immigration
he gave her a standard defense of the
benefits which immigration and brought
when he returned his car he did not
realize that his microphone was still on
and he complained about having been
brought to face to face with someone he
called and I quote a bigoted woman
widely reported on the media this
comment did little for brown's election
campaign
and confirmed in the minds of many
working-class voters that the Labour
leadership indeed the political class as
a whole took little interest in the
worries of ordinary people and were
happy to ignore them and these concerns
of high immigration became particularly
prominent after the credit crunch of
2008 and that financial collapse led to
fundamental changes in political
alignments and attitudes in many
democracies including I I believe
America changes which have by no means
yet worked themselves out and which are
still being felt because the credit
crunch resulted in those on low incomes
seeing their standard living stagnate
while the wealth of a better off seemed
to remain untouched the political and
financial elites had seemed less than
confident than competence I beg a pardon
in dealing with the fallout from the
crisis which cast doubt on a neoliberal
premise that allowing finances and
bankers to earn large sums of money
would be of benefit to the whole
community the credit crunch also seemed
to cast doubt on the wisdom of experts
economists who had explained that
inequality of income and wealth were
beneficial since they would help to
raise a standard of living of more less
well-off and the queen who often
represented the popular mood the queen
was visiting the London School of
Economics shortly after the credit
crunch and she asked the economist why
did neither you foresee this and that
was a question they found difficult to
answer so the experts were in the
popular mind discredited and it's
therefore not surprising that the
prediction of the experts about the
economic consequences of brexit in 2016
were also disregarded in the referendum
now Social Democrats in Britain and I
think elsewhere hope the credit crunch
would prove a social democratic moment
that it would lead to a fundamental
change in attitudes to the free market a
strong electoral constituency of a
greater regulation of markets and the
banks and in favor of redistributed
taxation now it's true the philosophy of
market liberalism has suffered a
battering and to show that I will quote
from the
serve tea parties manifesto for the
general election of 2017 it declared
remarkably we must reject the
ideological templates provided by the
Socialist Left and the libertarian right
in other words they were creating
Margaret Thatcher with Jeremy Corbyn and
instead embrace the mainstream view that
recognizes of the good that government
can do and later the manifesto declared
the government's agenda will not be
allowed to drift the right to reason may
the Prime Minister was as far away from
the economic liberals and Margaret
Thatcher Jeremy Corbyn was from Tony
Blair's new labour because the
beneficiary of the weakness in the
philosophy of market liberalism was not
social democracy but in Britain as in so
much of the continent and possibly in
America the two internationalist
philosophies associated with the
previous regime of economic progress
namely economic liberalism and social
democracy found themselves in retreat
and in decline and there was a change of
regime in many European countries and
also possibly in America Jeremy Corbyn
reacted against social democracy to
reason may reacted against neoliberalism
the 2000 election in Britain 2017
election marked a movement away from the
consensus on those two philosophies
which had ruled Britain from the days of
Margaret Thatcher in the 1980s to David
Cameron who resigned the Premiership in
2016 just after the brexit referendum
and what the credit crunch led to was
not a social democratic moment but as
after the Wall Street Crash a
nationalist and protectionist moment it
strengthened national feeling while
weakening class feeling and social
solidarity in the alienation and sense
of disfranchisement which arose
benefited the right more than the left
as it had done in 1930s Europe where
many socialists had wrongly predicted
the collapse of capitalism but although
the financial crash benefited the right
it gave rise to a mood which is radical
and anything but conservative on the
continent the main effect was to weaken
parties of the center in favor of
parties of the extreme right in the
Mediterranean countries often the
beneficiaries have been parties of the
extreme left but the main ideological
victims in both cases were
internationalist doctrines which has
been the governing ideologies for many
years and the credit crunch may be said
to have inaugurated a crisis of economic
and political liberalism and this was
bound to have considerable effects on
British membership of the European Union
and it led to a sea change and the
politics of many of the advanced
democracies because until 2008 politics
in Britain and many other democracies
was largely dominated by economics by
the role of the state in economic
affairs but after 2008 politics came to
be dominated by questions of identity
and in Britain a key question came to be
less what ought to be the role of the
state but rather what does it mean to be
British and in particular was being
British compatible with being European
and was being Scottish compatible with
being British in the 2015 general
election just a year before the
referendum on the European Union the
only two parties to make significant
progress well the United Kingdom
Independence Party dedicated to taking
taking Britain out of the European Union
and the Scottish National Party
dedicated of taking Scotland out of the
United Kingdom both emphasised identity
rather than economics they complained
not that their political opponents were
too left-wing or to right-wing but they
were insufficiently British or
insufficiently Scottish and these
concerns about identity were felt most
strongly by the disadvantaged and
insecure the victims of social and
economic change alienated from a bank
King financial and political
establishment which seemed to weather
the crisis with hardly any difficulty
the elite to them seemed not only
socially mobile benefiting from a
meritocratic society but also
geographically mobile they were located
in large conurbations such as London
Manchester and Newcastle all of which
supported remain the elites in Britain
perhaps our countries too is
internationalist it is more comfortable
in Brussels than it is in Blackpool or
Burnley perhaps in the United States
more comfortable in New York or Nassau
than Iowa or Idaho but lows left behind
by the decline of manufacturing industry
are neither socially nor geographically
mobile they remain rooted to their
decaying communities remarkably around
60% of the British population live
within 20 miles of where they grew up
they did not share the multicultural
perspective of Londoners who welcomed
emigration and favoured the European
Union and the contrast between London
and the rest of England may be one of
the reasons as you know Britain is
highly centralised it may be one of the
reasons why so many media commentators
based in the capital mister significance
of the grassroots insurgency in
provincial England which is leading to
brexit many of those who voted for
brexit felt they'd been ignored and felt
anger at the political and economic
establishment the referendum was an
opportunity to display that anger now
this growth of nationalism was bound to
have its effect shortly after David
Cameron's coalition government took
office in 2010 Europe once again became
a salient issue indeed in that election
of 2010 brexit gained 3 percent of the
vote now that may not seem high to you
but nearly a million votes its
percentage of the vote is the highest
recorded for any minor party in Britain
not allied to a major party since the
rise of labour before the first world
war in 2015 it gained 1/8 of ohh
though under our rather old electoral
system just one out of 650 seats in 2010
the near fascist British National Party
gained 2% of the vote a much better
performance than Oswald Moses British
Union of fascists between the wars which
despite the depression was never strong
enough to contest a general election now
in 2011 the Cameron government
established a petition system providing
with any petition on a matter of
government responsibility which
attracted a hundred thousand signatures
would be eligible for debate at
Westminster and the first such petition
demanding a referendum on the European
Union the second demanded a curb on
immigration at the same time a survey by
the polling company YouGov showed that
4/5 of the population in England
believed the country was too crowded
perhaps I should add that the petition
to STOP president trumps state visit to
Britain in 2017 attracted over a million
and a half signatures in October 2011 a
Commons debate was held on whether there
should be a referendum on British
membership of the European Union
eighty-one Conservative MPs nearly half
of all conservatives not on the
government payroll broke a three-line
whip to support a referendum grassroots
pressure on Cameron increased and in
January 2013 in his Bloomberg speech he
committed the Conservatives to
fundamental reform I quote of the EU and
then a referendum on whether Britain
should remain democratic consent for
Europe he declared was now wafer-thin if
the people were not to be consulted he
believed that would make more likely our
eventual exit since anti-eu feeling
would grow and fester he spoke of
negotiating a new settlement for Britain
in the EU and concluded with the
following words I want the EU to be a
success and I want a relationship
between Britain and the EU that keeps us
in it if we can negotiate such an
arrangement I will campaign for it with
all my heart and soul because I believe
something very deeply that Britain's
national interest is best served in a
flexible adaptable and open EU and that
certain EU is best with Britain in it
now his Bloomberg speech was a
pro-european speech though few
appreciate at a time
and he was more successful in his
renegotiation than his often thought
what he wanted to achieve was to ensure
that the rights of the non eurozone
members of which Britain of course was
one could not be overruled by the
majority of members who were in the
eurozone and seemed to be moving through
closer integration the banking Union
perhaps also fiscal union he sought in
particular to protect the City of London
which brought in much tax revenue and he
was successful but of course the
interests of the city could not be
brought to the fore in the referendum
since its image had been so tarnished in
the credit crunch vote to remain in
Europe now that the interests of the
city have been protected would not have
been a very inspiring slogan the emotive
issue was immigration and on this
although Cameron's occurred some minor
concessions they did not seem sufficient
to secure that it would be radically
curbed
now this speech of Cameron's at
Bloomberg marked a turning point in
Britain's relations with the EU because
until then governments had managed
successfully a balancing act
they didn't favor the aims of the
European Union in ever closing you ever
closer Union but they thought Britain's
economic interest would be best served
by Britain remaining in so they're
balanced it out with the euro sketch of
the British public by securing all sorts
of opt out from from from the central
policies and in this governments were
very successful they got as I said
knocked out from the eurozone they've
got an opt-out from the Schengen
Agreement which came into force in March
2006 abolishing internal border checks
within the European Union
but Cameron's speech and the European
referendum of 2016 showed the balancing
act could no longer be maintained now in
the 2016 referendum the dog that had
failed to bark in 1975 barked very
loudly remember I said the puzzle of
that referendum was why there wasn't a
national
populist movement of the kind there was
in Norway that kept Norway out of the
European Union in 2016 there was it was
you Kip led by Nigel Farage who proved
himself a brilliant communicator in the
media
and in the European Parliament elections
of 2014 you kicked was the largest party
with 27% of the vote the first time in
British history any party other than a
major party had won an election in 2016
the fear element which had played so
large a part in 1975 in keeping Britain
in the European Union now played them a
major part in pushing Britain out
because there was a fear being dragged
into integrationist projects and above
all a fear of uncontrolled immigration
and that was more important for most
voters than the economic consequences of
brexit and the referendum took place
against the background of a million
refugees being admitted to Germany and
terrorist attacks in Paris and Brussels
and that was legitimately linked up in
many people's minds with EU immigration
now Oxford University's migrant
Observatory I'm sorry migration
Observatory declared in the year or so
before the EU referendum immigration was
consistently named the most salient
issue facing the country peaking at 56%
in September 2015 these fears were
played upon by the brexit ears some of
whom put forward the blatant falsehoods
that the EU would short the EU would
shortly be admitting turkey that Britain
would have no veto over that decision
and that consequently 80 million Turks
would be able to come to Britain but
fair to say who had to look quite hard
in Britain to find any Turks and it's
also fair to say there were distortions
on both sides of the campaign because
after all referendums like general
elections are not academic seminars and
never like it to be but fears concerning
immigration were given effect by the
slogan of the brexit ears take back
control and furthermore deference
towards political leaders which have
been present in 1975 was no longer
present in 2006
many were conscious of the economic risk
but prepared to take them and some felt
they had listened to lose because their
own income had been stagnating and when
one political leader spoke in the
northeast and said that GDP would fall
if we left the European Union one
question I asked him whose GDP are you
talking about house has been stagnant
for many years now the referendum showed
that the country was deeply divided a
long a mutually reinforcing cleavage of
geography culture and education and
Britain remained deeply divided almost
down the middle along these fault lines
nearly three years after the referendum
and very remarkably brexit identity
remains much more powerful than party
identity 21 percent of British voters
say they have no party identity don't
identify with any party only six percent
of British voters say they don't
identify on brexit issue one way or the
other and that I think is a great change
the referendum outcome was confirmed by
the 200 2017 election in which both
major parties the conservative and
Labour Party said they would implement
the outcome and those two parties gained
84 percent of the vote between them the
Liberal Democrat Party which campaign
has campaigned consistently for a
further referendum and four remain 112
seats with 8% of the vote the Scottish
National Party which also campaigns for
the same lost farm was down from 56
seats to 35 seats and its vote was down
50% in Scotland to 37% in Scotland and
Parliament passed a European withdrawal
act which over 400 MPs voted for over
last year in which it was said that we
would withdraw from the European Union
on the 29th of March this year that date
has now been extended
- Halloween - October the 31st but it is
not clear
of course not wholly clear whether we
will in fact leave now the outcome of
this referendum in 2016 was unexpected
by most commentators and it will be
seismic in its effects already has been
I think I'm at the only complement in
Britain in the 20th century with
probably the general election of 1945 in
which Winston Churchill was dismissed by
the British public after winning the war
and at that time one elderly
disappointed voter said that the people
had elected a Labour government but the
country would never stand for it
and you may say the same about the
brexit referendum and there's a sense in
which like the 1945 election the
referendum was a victory for
working-class power because around 37%
of labour voters who would normally have
followed the cues of their party to vote
for Europe voted against it and this
helped to swing the balance in favor of
brexit in recent general elections the
working-class vote had seemed to count
for little because many working-class
voters live in safe labour seats and
under our first past the post system
there's no point campaigning in them so
the campaigning goes in the marginal
seats we're broadly the aspiration rules
live in the referendum every vote
counted and there was no such thing as a
safe seat and this no doubt was run
reasons for the high turnout 72% the
highest since the 1992 general election
and some voters were voting for the
first time since the general election of
1987 turnout was highest in the leave
areas there were three remain remain
errors Northern Ireland Scotland and
London and they were in the in the four
lowest errors of turnout but ironically
it was voters in those areas who are
most sympathetic to the call for a
second referendum not having turned out
in the first now the referendum showed
that the European Union had lost the
confidence of the British people though
some liberal I suppose elitists one
would say and I think financial times
which perhaps many of you read has taken
an opposite view and has said that the
people have forfeited the confidence of
the European Union and will have to
struggle hard to regain it they might
have borne in mind a poem written by the
German playwright Berthold Brecht after
the East German uprising of 1953 which
cited a leaflet by the secretary of the
Writers Union East Germany stating that
the people had forfeited the confidence
of the government and could only win it
back by redoubled efforts would it not
be easier in that case Brecht asked for
the government to dissolve the people
and elect another now the 2016
referendum was an emphatic repudiation
not only of the government but of the
political class as a whole all three
major political parties favored
remaining as did the nationalist parties
in the non-english parts of the United
Kingdom in the 1970s as I said last time
Edward Heath took the British
establishment into Europe but it needed
Harold Wilson to take the British people
into Europe through his referendum now
it appeared the British establishment
remained in Europe but the people did
not now the government having been
repudiated Cameron resigned and the
referendum had become an effect to
recall he was replaced by the Home
Secretary Theresa May also a remainer
but one committed to carrying out the
referendum verdict the high turnout in
the referendum seems to me a striking
illustration of Democratic commitment on
the part of the least fortunate in
Britain greatest threat to democracy we
always used to say was an inert
electorate one that has ceased to think
about public issues or to take part in
politics
John Stuart Mill once wrote that we
learn to swim or cycle not by reading
books about swimming or cycling but by
undertaking the activity and similarly
we learn about democracy not by reading
books about it but by participating in
making decisions but the outcome of the
referendum confirmed the doubts that
many liberals feel concerning the
doctrines of the sovereignty of the
people and these doubts have been shared
before the first referendum by Ralph a
ex-president of the European Commission
who had deplored the coming referendum
he said a referendum on this matter
consists of consulting people who don't
know the problems instead of consulting
people who know them I would deplore a
situation in which the policy of this
great country should be left to
housewives it should be decided instead
by trained and informed people and
modern liberals find themselves in
curious alliance with 19th century
conservatives who opposed the extension
of the franchise arguing the people were
too ill educated too prone to be moved
by demagogues and unable to understand
complex political issues some have come
ruefully to sympathize with the view of
a great French reactionary and opponent
of the French Revolution and Joseph de
Maistre who said the principle of the
sovereignty of the people is so
dangerous that even if it were true it
would be necessary to conceal it now as
well as the vote against the political
class the referendum was a cry of Rage
by those who saw themselves as the
victims of globalization
it was the revenge of the betrayed they
sought protection against the excesses
of globalization in which the EU's
internal market was a symbol protection
against market forces which so they
believed were costing their jobs and
holding down their wages but bad
terrible irony brexit is likely to
strengthen those very forces in Britain
and not we
and indeed most of the leaders of the
brexit campaign apart from you Kip were
conservatives of the right who while
agreeing that if the new immigration
would be restricted had a totally
different agenda they thought brexit for
basically neoliberal reasons to ensure a
more effective operation of the market
economy freed from the constraints of
the EU and the restrictions of wracked
the laws social Europe they agreed with
Margaret Thatcher that the EU would
prevent Britain benefiting from the
workings of the market economy they
believed of Britain free of EU
regulations and restrictions could be a
powerful global trading force they
wanted to create Singapore on Thames in
London as it were and this economically
liberal view of brexit is bound to
prevail in my view it is the logic of
brexit because economic success outside
the European Union requires Britain to
be more competitive by opening up
markets and embracing free trade
encouraging enterprise by lowering
corporation tax and personal tax as well
to be financed only by reducing public
expenditure this will put further
pressure on social and welfare
expenditure already reeling from some
years of austerity it means a radical
shrinking of the state which is likely
to disadvantage those very voters who
believe that brexit would protect them
from the excesses of globalization far
from gaining shelter from world economic
forces they will find themselves even
more exposed to them they will have to
sink or swim in the harsher economic
climate in which post brexit will find
herself so brexit will lead for Britain
more not less exposed to the forces of
globalization it will prove to be the
Revenge of Margaret Thatcher from beyond
the grave one writer when just before
Britain entered the European Union
delivered the wreath lectures and he
gave them on the BBC prestigious
lectures and gained the title journey to
an unknown destination this journey is
still unknown
although in my last lecture on Wednesday
I shall be discussing what that
destination might be but whatever that
destination is Britain will almost
certainly not be part of it she is not
part of what Robert Schuman spoke of
that destiny shared in common of the
European states and she has probably
never been part of it in a poll in 2016
the British came 28th out of the 28
member states of identifying themselves
as Europeans nearly two-thirds of
British did not identify as Europeans as
compared with an average of 62% who did
identify themselves as Europeans in the
EU as a whole only countries approaching
Britain's low level of identification
with Europe were Greece and Cyprus which
had suffered serious financial crises in
recent years Europe therefore has caused
a deep conflict between the facts of
economics which seem to point to
continued membership and the sentiments
of nationhood which point to brexit
perhaps it is not wholly surprising that
the sentiment of nationhood has
triumphed but the process of breaks it
whatever its difficulties has not shaken
the foundations of the British political
system and she still remains probably
the most stable country in Western
Europe among the most stable countries
in the world and they've been all sorts
of dire predictions but it's worth
remembering what was said in 1777 after
general Burgoyne's surrendered the
Americans at Saratoga and a young
British aristocrat set Adam Smith this
is going to ruin the country and Smith
said there was a great deal of ruin in
an ocean and I think those are wides
words and perhaps worth remembering
amidst the tumult brexit thank you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the fourth one will
be in the auditorium downstairs on
Wednesday we have we started late and I
apologized for that it was trying to get
the chairs now those things around there
will be a little time for a few
questions however I just want to say
myself I not heard so insightful and
remarkable empathetic way of describing
the reasons for EMEA alienation of that
British electorate that working-class
electric over these time so I myself
learned a great deal
thank you for ladies and gentlemen
Justin if you get identified by the
speaker somebody now I'm asking a
question could he also identify yourself
please
please far away I'm sorry I've gone a
bit too long I stunned them into silence
yeah okay sorry political science with
an interesting history is coefficient
politics but you may be getting from the
exit and you talked about the tension in
Margaret Thatcher's days between the
economics the pro-business right and the
nationalism for Britain but in your
characterization of the king the
contemporary conservative parties it
seems like you're describing those
aligning again even though there's been
such an opposition to your exit from
established business interests and I
just wondering how you see that working
within the ideology and the mindset of
the current conservative party if there
is still attention to the seat or if
somehow it's come together in some
unforeseen week that's a difficult
question to answer the tension now is
between those as you say the financial
and business interests who are best
represented by the chancellor who want
what is called a fairly soft brexit
maintaining close ties to the European
Union and what you might call the harder
people and there's a very difficult
balance and perhaps not a very happy one
because if you're very close to the
European Union and remain let's say to
take an extreme
model you remain in the customs union
and the internal market that makes it a
pointless brexit what's the point of
leaving but accepting the same rules but
you will get reasonably frictionless
trade on the other hand if you want to
strike out to become Singapore on Thames
which is what the right wing of the
Conservative Party to you will not get
frictionless trade now given that the
continent is Britain's closest market
it's an unhappy dilemma situation to be
in which practice wasn't thought about
much when the vote took place and the
the conflict within the Conservative
Party now is on that it's fair to say
one gets a very false picture of opinion
by reading the Financial Times for
example amongst conservative members and
it's worth remembering we have a
leadership election very shortly because
to reason may said you'll go once the
deal is passed and see I in my opinion
she may go before that I think her days
of out numbered the election for leader
is determined by the parliamentary party
voting for two candidates who are then
put to the members now the members are
very untypical of british opinion
they're only a hundred twenty four
thousand of them the average age is over
sixty and they are strong brexit ears
fifty percent favor britain leaving the
european union without a deal fewer than
ten percent are remainders or favor of
second referendum and given that is a
situation the candidates for the
leadership of which it said they're
about twenty are varying to that
position and teresa may is in a sense
out on a limb towards the soft people
and particularly in my view annoyed
people by opening discussions with
corbin they say she should be talking
the right wing of her own party and not
legitimizing someone they see as a
marxist who's with threats of the
security of the country so I think her
days are very much numb but I don't know
that answers your question
the nationalist right of the
Conservative Party ignoring the CBI for
example oh yeah now that that that's
absolutely right they are and one of the
leaders of the nationalist right Boris
Johnson said of business a word
beginning with F and then business and
that's a bit on perhaps on typical
conservative view but they they say it's
it's fair to say they say the CBI is
representative of large business which
can cope with EU bureaucracy and
paperwork and small businesses can't but
it's certainly true that the rep that
those are the closest to the business
and financial community like the chance
of the Exchequer are very soft brexit
ears that absolutely right but there's a
the basis of the Conservative Party is
and always has been and the basis of the
Thatcherite partially consent
politically not very wealthy but those
with small amounts of capital and fear
losing it small shopkeepers small
businessmen aspiring SI toos and so are
not very rich the the constituency is
not that and those are the people are
going to elect the leader and that's the
the basis of the modern Conservative
Party I think yes gentlemen here it's
almost three years since we had a very
close
when this occurred almost three years
ago there was less information we
diffused in the country people went to
the Falls anyway and made a decision and
you had a close election why not go back
well the art the argument was this that
both major parties in the elections said
they would respect the result now there
are calls and the Labour Party is moving
towards the position new suggests and if
it was another leader than Corbin I
think the Labour Party would have come
out for that position but the the and I
I would say my own position for what
it's worth I used to favor that option
but I don't anymore for a reason I'll
explain the argument against is this
that opinion seems to have changed
slightly towards the remain side since
that referendum but that is not there's
been a huge churning of opinion and some
people who are leave are now remain and
simply remain leave but the new element
is the to two things of people who
didn't vote last time because but they
couldn't be bothered to vote and the
young who were too young to vote and
would vote this time and those two
elements give remain a small majority
now there are a lot of people I think
rather foolish people who say perhaps
lightly tactlessly we lock the older
dying out and the young growing up from
bed a vote and therefore there'll be a
movement of opinion towards Europe well
not to be careful saying that because
after all 1975 gave a two-to-one
majority for Europe now that cohort
which is now much older is very hostile
to at the old of much more hostile to
Europe from the young but it's that same
cohort that gave Europe a huge majority
975 but anyway let's assume that the
polls are right and that remain had a
small majority let's say for argument's
sake 5446 which probably best think of
it would that actually resolve it all
the people say well wait a minute
this is also reasonably narrow immature
let's have a third referendum yeah
this we can ignore the big question in a
democracy would be let's do what the
Civil War yeah
and almost three years ago we had an
outcome there has been a lot of debate
there has been a fiasco you without
president administered by the Prime
Minister
I'm quoting the FT in the Economist I
think they're both in favor of having
certain people declares no absolutely
absolutely our liberal elitist in
Britain are very bad losers they don't
like losing votes they say have enough
people couldn't really mean it another
one but no I take a point and the
difficulty isn't say if it was a narrow
majority this too would be seen as
provisional and the point was that
before that first referendum the
government sent a information leaf it's
every house saying the result whatever
it is would be respected
and you may say it's famous in the
Scottish nationalists are in a way in
two minds about this for this reason but
they say if we had a referendum on
independence people would want to won on
the principle and won on the deal now if
we'd had that if it had had been known
the leave vote in the 2016 referendum
would've been high because people say it
wasn't no harm in voting and let's see
what deal we get we can always change
our mind so I'm a bit of a problem there
and another problem with it is this that
um what are the options to be put them
so you may say leave on the basis of the
deal or remain but the right wing of the
conservative party say no no we want to
leave on the basis of No Deal
and then the Labour Party says no we
want to leave on the basis of a customs
union and some set on the Norway option
so what option you can put in but
despite that I was in favor of the
referendum I now think it is too late a
referendum bill that the 2015 one took
seven months to get through Parliament
and you can imagine how it would be
fought over with MPs and might in my
view it may not be shared I think the
MPs have behaved appallingly because if
they favored a referendum they should
have pushed that through earlier not
left it to the last minute
and suddenly on the other issues and
what the end piece have done is to vote
for the withdrawal act to take us out
but then vote against every means to
implement it it reminds me of the old
Groucho Marx film in the nineteen
thirties when Groucho's and academic
with a a group a governing body of
academics and he starts a discussion by
saying I don't care what you say
whatever it is I'm against it and this
is what the MPs have done tying her
hands so there is it's a very difficult
issue there is some case of logic and
again that's dividing the country almost
down the middle on balance now I'm
against it yeah sorry I've talked too
much meets witching hour for this
Monday's lecture the final lecture where
everything is ladies and gentlemen but
you cheap euro reminds me that to tell
you about it's going to be in the
auditorium downstairs Wednesday
[Applause]
[Music]